finally there is a major story that is
developing right now as we speak in
relation to one of these awful stories
about an unarmed black guy who was
killed because the police appear to have
been way too heavy-handed in making an
arrest as a result of this now there is
looting in Minneapolis where the arrest
occurred there's there's rioting going
on in Los Angeles for some reason you
can see the looters there videos of them
going all around the internet you can
see the looters in Minneapolis just
robbing a Target store yeah so just poor
you know pouring in pouring out stealing
a bunch of stuff I have a hot take on
this Hut take is looting is bad that's
my Hut take I know controversial looting
is bad
obviously police brutality if that's
what occurred here looks like it did
that's very bad too there are
investigations into that Donald Trump's
DOJ is now investigating that he says
justice will be served
that's a good thing there's there's no
excuse here for looting doesn't look
good and in Los Angeles but what I was
looking at some of the looting it looks
like some of them aren't even the BLM
protesters who are rioting it's actually
an Tifa I would recognize those pallid
little socialists anywhere there seem to
be other groups involved as well tragic
that that a man died good that there's
an investigation civil society is a
delicate thing that's my big takeaway on
big tech on Pope foutch II on Jimmy
Kimmel almost getting canceled 20 years
later on on all of these things on the
looting civil society is a delicate
thing it's not so simple as we have a
constitution we have a set of laws
everything is going to be hunky-dory
because there it is it's written down
it's not so simple as we be we've
behaved in certain ways in the past so
now we'll be fine there's there's no
amount that we can exert on our society
that will crack it it's delicate it's a
civil society can be broken by corrupt
officials it can be broken by corrupt
businessmen maybe in big tech it can be
broken by
people who go looting it can it can be
broken we are now in a position where we
are being encouraged mostly by the left
to break that society why does the
progressive left want to break the
society is they don't like the society
that much that's why their presidents
say they want to fundamentally transform
that society that's why they engage in
criticism all the time of that society
trying to progress forward into the
future if you want to conserve any of
that society then you've got to be
careful we've got to be a little bit
more delicate with our institutions with
our traditions and with each other
[Music]
[Music]